you had best be ready
after the second war against the orcish
horde King gen Greymane sealed away his
country behind a massive wall to protect
his people isolated from the rest of the
world a terrible curse swept through the
land forever changing the Gilman's now
gen Greymane has left his home to enter
the Nexus bringing with him the curse of
the worgen Greymane is a shape-shifting
assassin can whittle down his foes from
range and transform to finish them off
remains passive trait curse of the
warden highlights his power to transform
between a human and warden when certain
abilities are used as a human Greymon
attacks with his pistol at range as a
worgen Greymane
dives into the fight as a melee attacker
dealing bonus damage
his first ability as a human is gilma in
cocktail Greymane hurls an unstable
elixir towards an enemy that explodes on
contact dealing light damage to its
initial target and heavy damage to any
enemies behind it
as a worgen gray mains queue changes to
razor swipe with a powerful slash he
lunges forward and deals damage to any
enemies in range both forms benefit from
unleashing grey Mane's inner beast
this ability greatly increases his
attack speed refreshing its duration
with each continued attack should the
buff happen to fall off the ability will
enter a short cooldown gray Mane's third
ability dark flight causes him to leap
at an enemy dealing damage while
shape-shifting into worgen form as a
worgen gray Mane's ability becomes
disengaged
allowing him to roll out of melee range
while transforming back into a human
of course the sword is just for show
gray Maine's first heroic go through the
throat is as direct as it sounds he
leaves towards his target shifting into
warden formed and slashing multiple
times for heavy damage if he manages to
take out an enemy using this ability for
a short time he can cast it again for
free
mark for the kill is Greymane second
heroic option using this ability shifts
Greymane back into human form firing a
single flan range shot that marks the
first heroic contacts mark targets take
increased damage from all sources and
Greymon can reactivate the ability to
leave towards the target from shifting
into organ form switching between human
and worgen form is a delicate art
skilled players will know when to remain
at range poking an opponent down in
human form versus charging in as a
worgen for maximum damage use dark
flight to dive towards an enemy with low
health snatching up a kill be careful
though diving in with dark flight could
cost you your life if the enemy team is
prepared when in worgen form used this
engage as a means to escape from
dangerous situations it is important to
keep in mind that grey maids core
weakness is his lack of self-sustained
as a player make sure you have support
heroes backing you up when opposing
Greymane capitalize on moments when he's
out of position as all damage dealt will
stay you'll naen cocktail and inner
beast are Grey mains main tools of
destruction in length
switching to organ form and using razor
swipe against minions can also aid
you're pushing potential in teamfights
use this ability as an effective means
to maneuver around quickly in melee
range looking to finish fights for your
team go for the throat is the heroic for
you dive in on a target and apply a
substantial amount of damage if timed
correctly and used in succession framing
has the potential to mop up teamfights
for those confident in their skill shots
March for the kill is an aggressive
heroic that your whole team can
capitalize on
use the vulnerability applied to the
target to encourage focus from your team
then dive in as a worgen to finish the
job
Greymane is the master of his curse
unleashing the Beast within to turn the
tide of battle to his favor mastered the
art of shape-shifting and no foe will
escape your wrath make sure to subscribe
to heroes of the storm here on YouTube
and around the web and we'll see you in
the Nexus